Hi i'm Benjamin Herrmann and I will be showing
how you can perform resolvent analysis using
time resolved flow field measurements exclusively
and without recourse to the governing equations.
This is work presented in a recent paper
titled data-driven resolved analysis
which I wrote in collaboration with Peter Baddoo
from Imperial college; Richard Semaan from TU
Branschweig; Steve Brunton from University of
Washington; and Beverley McKeon from Caltech.
The paper is available on archive and you can
find a link to it in the description below.
So say you have a linear stable system
that's being periodically forced,
then the long term response in the frequency
domain is governed by this expression, where
this is the resolvent operator. This operator
encodes how any disturbances to the system are
filtered by the linear dynamics to produce a
response in the context of non-normal systems.
We know that the resultant behaves as a very
selective amplifier of disturbances and because
of this it is critical to understand the dynamics
of such systems. This was first pointed out in the
work of Trefethen encountered in the context of
shear flows. Since then there has been a growing
interest in using this method mainly due to its
relevance to the design of flow control strategies
by using the input output framework developed by
Jovanovich and Bamieh and also to do its relevance
to identifying structures and scale interactions
in turbulent flows by using the interpretation of
non-linearities as forcing proposed by McKeon and
Sharma. And even though we know it's important and
there is this great interest from the community
in applying resolvent analysis to flows with two
or three inhomogeneous directions, this is still
not commonplace and one of the main reasons for
this is that resolvent analysis requires under
hood access to high fidelity numerical solvers
of the linearized governing equations. In this
work we develop a purely data-driven method
that can work with black box numerical solvers
and doesn't require access to adjoint solutions,
so it opens up the possibility of eventually
doing resolvent fully from experimental data.
So now we'll be showing you how does the method
work and for that i will be using data from
direct numerical simulations of plane channel
flow and all the details of the numerical setup
are in our paper the first step is to
collect a sequence of state snapshots
from recording of a transient simulation starting
from a perturbation uh to the stable system
so in this case the state corresponds
to the three velocity components in this
three-dimensional flow field which here
i'm visualizing as velocity iso surfaces
then we can enrich our data set by considering
additional recordings of transients
starting from different initial conditions
the second step is to assemble our data matrix
matrices which is just stretching the state into
a very long vector and horizontally concatenating
these states according to your temporal sequence
followed by the temporal sequence
corresponding to the next initial condition
and the next initial condition and so on and
actually the ordering in fact it's not really
important what's important is that all the columns
in the y matrix correspond to the columns in the x
matrix but everything shifted one time step into
the future and the f matrix that you see there
is just a waiting to adjust the inner
product so that the l2 norm measures
a physically meaningful quantity which in
this case is the perturbation kinetic energy
now that we have these matrices we use dynamic
mode decomposition to approximate the leading
eigenvectors and eigenvalues of the underlying
linear operator that involves our measurements
and we use this learned eigen decomposition
to build our resultant operator but
projected onto eigen coordinates
and we perform resultant analysis so the singular
value decomposition of the resultant on these
coordinates this projection of the resolvent was
first used by radiant henningsen a while back
in 1993 where they used it to reduce the
computational cost of computing resolvent gains
but in their case they used the actual eigen
decomposition of the system from a known operator
whereas here we're using learned eigenvectors and
eigenvalues that we learned from data using dmd
so the last step is to synthesize
our resultant modes back into
physical coordinates so if we
had enough data we we will get
a good approximation of the actual resultant
modes of the system and here i'm showing the
optimal forcing where i'm showing a
world normal velocity iso surfaces
and the optimal response for channel flow where
i'm showing stream wise velocity iso surfaces
so these are the familiar stream waste
voltages causing stream west tricks
and here are some more results so these are
the operator-based resultant modes just for
ground truth comparison and these are the ones
obtained from data using a data set that was
generated starting from these initial conditions
where this middle plot shows the learned dmd
spectrum overlaid on top of the true spectrum
and these are the data-driven resulting modes
for this data set we needed to retain 200 dmd
modes to get this approximation now what happens
if we use the optimal forcing as an initial
condition to generate our data set well in that
case we only need 20 dmd modes to generate an even
better approximation of the true resolvent modes
and what's more interesting is that we are
actually learning a very specific region of
the spectrum which is something that we noticed
so the last result that i want to show you
is what happens when you use a localized
disturbance as the initial condition
to generate the data set here we're using
this doughnut-shaped perturbation which is
something that resembles what you would get in an
experiment with a well normal jet so in this case
we get these modes which are quite
different from the true resultant modes
so this the question that arises is
are these results useful how do they
relate to the operator the actual operator of
the system and how can we interpret these modes
it turns out that if we do an operator-based
resolvent analysis but where we restrict the
input and output spaces to be in the span of
the data snapshots then we get the same modes
so this means this is very encouraging because it
means that these results are still very valuable
we just need to be aware that what we are
getting are these forcing and response modes
that are constrained to
live in the span of our data
which completely makes sense okay so these
are some points that i want to leave you with
first this data-driven resolvent analysis
inherits its capabilities and limitations from dmd
so computational cost noise robustness data
efficiency all depend on what dmd variant
you're using also we want to point out that we
found that it's very important that we develop
more effective ways to explore the
state space of dynamical systems
i also want to point out that this is the
first step towards a fully experimental
resolvation analysis and we believe
that this work contributes to lowering
the barrier of entry to resultant research and
applications and finally a final remark is that
we recognize that there is still a critical
step missing before we can make the leap to
data-driven resultant of turbulent flows
which is we need to disseminate the linear
from the non-linear dynamics and that's actually
something that we're working on at the moment
okay so thanks for watching again
there are a lot more details
in the paper and you can find a link to
it in the description below thank you